the physics who sneezes is at the heart
of understanding how pathogens of one
individual become the pathogens of
another so without that step of
Transportation of the pathogens from one
host to the other there is no epidemic
there is no disease transmission and it
turned out that we don't actually
understand much about that physics so
the work that we do is combining food
mechanics to problems that are relevant
in health and epidemiology to understand
better how pathogens are
[Music]
transmitted I started being interested
in sneezes when uh I finished a piece of
work on influenza
transmission and while doing that work
what we realized is that the parameter
choices to describe the contamination
process from one host to another are
very limited the process SE themselves
are not really well known and so when
you're sitting you know in the head for
example of of a hospital like MGH or or
else and uh and trying to figure out
okay we have right now an epidemic that
is on going what kind
of measures should I ask my sta staff to
take they are guessing right
now you're in the lab right now which is
a BL2 lab so bios safety level two so
I'll take you all around we're in the
middle of a move so it's a little
cluttered this is basically the
microbiology corner here in this area
it's a lot of work uh that entails
looking at fragmentation and breakup
from more fundamental level and these
are the type of cameras that uh we used
for characterizing ex violent
expirations cough sneezes this
particular one is basically uh a camera
that allow us to go to about a million
frame per seconds and the reason why we
need these very high frame rates because
these events happen very quickly so we
tried all sorts of approaches to try to
trigger this sneezes some included know
light sensitivity pepper various
additives but I really wanted to achieve
a natural sneeze and so ultimately the
method that ended up being reproducible
at all times was no stickling and so no
stickling is the universal
method sneezes are actually really
interesting they're multiphase turbulent
clouds uh so there's all sorts of scales
also involved but at the same time it's
a complex flow because have a gas use
phase that is coupled with droplets and
eventually the final residue of these
drops which could be you know solid
residues containing the pathogens and so
there's a lot of very interesting open
problems of physics and flu Dynamics
embedded in it at this point we
understand much better how sneezes and
coughs actually functions the overall
Dynamic of contamination so the second
part of the story outward from from the
patient is right now something that we
understand quite well the only only
aspects that we still are working on is
to refine the question of how is that
affecting the actual fate of the
pathogens ultimately from the other side
of the story which is going backward in
the host there's still a lot of open
questions uh but we're planning to uh
look at them once we go to phase two of
the work bringing in human subjects that
are both infected and healthy because we
start then to also look at the
differences in the physiology and uh the
the long Capac City in health and
infection and how all of that can
modulate what we already saw in terms of
emissions outside of the
[Music]
mouth